look if you're somebody that's consumed
by content before you know that
everything I talked about pretty much
comes from a place of wanting to make it
better how can we improve how can we
make progress so that is the only way I
view things even stuff that's very
emotional and personal to me like u.s.
Iran some of the challenges that we
faced in the past before so the
disclaimer I want to give you up front
is if you have a hard time being
objective right now or if you have a
hard time being able to watch a video
and reasoning today because your
emotions are too high I suggest you not
watch this video today or maybe this
week maybe watch it two weeks from now
but don't watch it to now completely
respect you for doing that now having
said that the other thing I want you to
keep in mind is the fact that value
taemin is very comfortable talking about
controversial topics I don't know that
I've never touched up on no
controversial topics all the Mafia
interviews political interviews you know
people have had that they've said you
shouldn't have this guy because this
guy's gotten you know deep platform you
shouldn't bring that guy politically
that guy's too Democrat that guy's too
Republican that person sooo too many
people he's killed too many people this
guy so we've had a lot of different
controversial people on this channel and
I'm comfortable doing that and the way
we do it we don't do it from a bandwagon
standpoint which is let me see what I
need to say to get my viewers to like me
more because it's all about liking and
if they like you you do better it's not
my style I didn't create a channel to do
vlogs and you see my life on my dogs and
my puppies on my cats and look how
awesome it is oh my gosh I love this guy
it's not my DNA that's not how much so I
tell you based on how I view things and
the things that are experienced in my
life so if that makes sense to you then
great if it doesn't I also respect it
you don't have to agree with what I'm
talking about you can comment below and
trash this video if you want to I'm
comfortable with that as well but this
is my response video to events that took
place with the death of George Floyd so
today we're gonna talk about the feud a
few different things one is events facts
one is you know some of the things
that's good actually of what's happened
with this crisis that we've experienced
then we talk about who and what is the
cause of the events that took place with
Georg Freud who is to blame who benefits
from America being divided why does it
keep happening can racism and
discrimination be eliminated and in some
solutions for you to be thinking about
at the end which we'll talk about here
in a few minutes so let me get right
into it facts Georg Freud 46 year-old
man gets up there New York Times tells
us 8 minutes and 40 seconds Derek Chavan
was on his neck Derek Sheldon was on his
neck for 8 minutes and 46 seconds while
George Floyd is saying I can't breathe
please I can't breathe everybody
screaming he's saying he can't breathe
get off of him
but the man the officer kept the knee on
his neck for 8 minutes and 46 seconds
you think about it for a second if you
do MMA and you watch UFC you don't even
do MMA if you watch UFC when the guy
gets tapped out what do they do they go
like this and the mediator the ref comes
in boom
how long have you seen guy go like this
actually think about the question UFC
chokehold
how long have you seen the guy tapped
out how long 2 seconds 3 seconds you
ever seen 8 minutes and 46 seconds I
don't know that's a long time I've never
seen 8 minutes and 47 the roundest 5
minutes what do you do for 8 minutes and
46 seconds and you got 3 other people
for other people there that could
actually help you out 3 other people and
nothing happens so absolute disgraceful
would took place and I'm not surprised
that it upset a lot of people now the
people involved there are children
obviously is the main officer with the
knee on the leg 37 year old by the way
he was charged with third degree murder
second degree manslaughter then he had
officer Koons himself officer lane and
officer tau they were charged with
aiding and abetting murder okay one of
them was 26 years old 137 134 years old
so that's them those are the facts that
we have so far here right so that's what
they've been charged so far which by the
way these could change and odds are
Derek is going to go to jail and if I'm
a betting man I'm assuming the other
three are going to be released based on
how these things typically have worked
out in the past okay he'll go to jail
the rest of them and by the way how long
he goes to jail I don't know because if
you go back and think about somebody
that's close to him back in March of
1991 Rodney King went through a similar
challenge where his son of sergeant Kunz
Stacy Koons
told the other four officers to hit you
know Rodney
with the baton and there were constantly
being hit and that was recorded back in
the days when we didn't have social
media and Rodney King was 25 years old
at the time
George fraud was is was 46 years old
Rodney King survived Georg Freud didn't
survive stacey koon went to jail for 30
months so we make the comparison
Rodney didn't die 30 months and then
afterwards today he's a limo driver by
the way can actually go we'll put the
link below for you guys to watch he's a
limo driver for a company called music
Express he's driven Al Gore DL Hughley
and other people around by the way every
time he goes in LA and and he drives
people around people record him and say
hey how does it feel do you regret what
you do to Rodney King he's had to live
with that event his entire life and fYI
that riot caused 63 people to die in LA
I came to the state November 28th 1990
this event was March 3rd 1991 four
months after I came to the state this
took place okay so the 92 riots were
obviously later on but I came to the
stage during that time I was actually
absolutely scary on what was going on
people had no clue what was going I was
12 years old I didn't speak English you
turn on the TV
everybody's agitated and I'm in the
middle of it in LA so those are some of
the people involved here so we don't
know how long you should get but it can
be life but it's gonna be definitely
more than 30 months so that's one thing
we'll see what's gonna happen there the
other person that's involved in this
case is the camera person which is a 17
year old young lady
Darnell affray sure who's recording the
entire time herself and while she's
recording at the following day her video
is the one that goes viral and you can
see there's a video of her talking
saying I cannot believe what happened it
happened right here she's crying in
tears people are trying to comfort her
happen right here the video went viral I
cannot believe I witnessed this whole
thing she's talking about this so those
are some of the events now let's talk
about the next part on why she plays
such an important role the worst
invention for bad cops and criminals the
worst invention for bad cops and
criminals is this right here this is by
far the worst invention this right here
is the worst invention for bad cops and
criminals
I've sat with many mafia members I've
sat with Sammy the bull Gravano Michael
Francis Frank Cullotta
I mean you too
you name him I probably Philip Leonetti
Ralph Natali all the bosses anybody
that's pretty much a boss or somebody
that was an influential figure in a mob
world I pretty much sat down with them
right they will tell you this is the
worst time to be a mobster
why because our phones so social media
phones and cameras have ruined
everything for bad cops and criminals
this is a bad time to be in a crime
business and this is a bad time to be a
cop now watch this what is changing
everything is citizen journalism she may
not know it but at 17 years old
Darnell afraser502 thousand nine hundred
full-time journalists that worked for
the fourteen hundred newspapers no she's
a citizen journalist she takes this out
she records a life she's officially a
city citizen journalists believe it or
not this is very very important and
positive for advancement very very
because nowadays how many videos have
you seen where the driver takes out the
camera puts it on the cop and the cop
says you put that phone down stop
recording me and a man says I know my
rights what I do - I'm a police officer
and the driver says I'm a lawyer
and a police officer a lawyer who does
uber yes I need to make money I'm a
lawyer and I know my loss okay then keep
recording but there's many of these
videos by the way this scares the hell
out of bad cops this is a weapon so
remember this this is a beautiful thing
right here that's a weapon right so now
let's continue let's continue obviously
this event takes place we're divided ok
we're divided what's going on what do we
do but if you look at cops and
protesters when it comes to cops you got
good cops bad cops and criminals yes yes
protesters some people want to protest
and want to kind of be hurt we're upset
White House we go in front of DC hey
we're upset LA we're upset
there's peaceful protesters there's
looters and criminals on both sides you
have criminals and both sides you have
bad cops and looters on both sides you
have people that exploit opportunities
crimes going on let me go grab this
Louie back that's criminal crimes going
on let me get this Tesla car injure
crimes go let me drive this car crimes
gonna let me go and get this target let
me get this computer let me get this ID
criminal crimes going on oh I'm a cop
let me show you my badge I got a gun you
better listen to me
right that's abuse when you exploit but
we have to realize majority cops are
good people yes yes majority of
protesters are peaceful yes yes we found
an area of commonality it's very easy
right now to find things that we don't
agree with area of commonality most cops
are good cops I'm willing to bet
somebody in your family or friends or
cousin somebody's a cop yes and I'm
willing to bet that somebody you know
when I'm protested and they're a
peaceful protester yes perfect so it's
not that everybody's bad it's not that
every cop is bad it's not that every
protesters bad it's the fact that there
are one that make the rest look bad
there are a few that make the rest look
back we can't forget about this now I
also understand this topic being an
emotional topic I did a video the other
day with Maya actually did it soon with
all my brokers in the company and I
asked everybody to have an emergency
meeting for me to have my say with them
so they heard it from me first before I
make the video for you I don't want to
make the video on value tainment and
then make the video to you this whole
event took place at the end of the month
and the end of the month for my business
the busiest days when I'm working 16 17
hour days because it's closed and it was
the biggest month we ever had in May so
I give this message to them now I'm
giving a message to you so now let's
talk about this next part here okay
let's talk about this next part it's
very easy when you are not emotionally
attached to a situation to give your
opinion on things let me explain
it's very easy while we're talking about
this year and I'm writing the stuff out
I'm preparing for my setting notes our
food comes from Jersey Mike I tell one
of my guys here and I said look if your
father just passed away you're
emotionally grieving if my father's
never passed away I don't know the pain
but I can say I understand I wish you
nothing but the best it's gonna be all
right time's gonna heal all wounds you
know these things that people say right
how do I know I don't know I've never
had my father died 30 minutes later our
camera guy Paul comes up to us we're
having lunch over there Jersey Mike eyes
I'm sitting here Josh my wife is right
here he comes and he says you can tell
something's bothering him he comes in
Manisa what's that my I just got a call
right now my dad just passed away I said
what he said my dad just passed away we
all look at each other because just 30
minutes prior to that we spoke about
that and Kai's like looking this I don't
want to think about getting that call
your dad just passed on my dad just
passed by I went up that's Alyssa man if
you got to go home come soon I'm gonna
get out of here two weeks ago Memorial
Day he went to his family to visit is
that two weeks that is that dies he came
to Pat I got to go visit my Stu do your
thing two weeks Eddie's father passed
away my dad is still alive I can say man
I am so sorry I feel your pain I don't
know the pain I don't know the pain so
it's naive and arrogant for somebody who
is emotionally not experienced what's
being experienced today to be able to
logically say I fully understand where
you're coming from I mean I totally
understand why somebody doesn't want to
hear any of this stuff this is why I
said if you can't objectively watch
something today or be bit with a reason
today because emotions are so high don't
even worry about watching it come back
to it a couple weeks later if you're
watching to write them more power to you
but I understand why not - because
there's logic there's emotion there is
reason there's feelings when feelings
are high when emotions are high we don't
reason well we don't logic well when our
feelings are high when our feelings are
low we're able to reason better why
don't you say I'm gonna tell you I'm
gonna pop I'll get killed I'll you you
don't even know what I'm gonna do with
you step away one minute two minutes
five minutes one hour two hours three
hours yeah man I'm full so it's gonna
get ugly I'm glad I'm calmer now things
are better right in this situation one
day two days three days four days one
week two weeks three weeks kamar right
because we're able to reason better so
I'm also not naive and I know how
frustrating it is when people who have
never had kids they tell people how to
parent well when people who have never
ran a company are telling people how to
run a company when people who have never
been poor want to claim they know what
it like what it's like to be poor when
people who have never been on welfare oh
I feel so bad
I grew up as a kid going and picking up
welfare and my mother with sent me to
Albertsons on Glen Dale to go pick up
women products as a thirteen-year-old
kid you know what's the worst thing that
thirsty no kid wants to do is that but I
also know what it's worth to be worth be
worth a couple hundred why because I was
there hated it changed it Chapelle said
when I was a kid my dad would tell me
turn off the heat or turn off the heat I
got so sick of it I told my dad I'm
gonna make so much money I can leave the
heat on as much as I want because I'm
sick of being broke right that that can
produce different kind of emotions if
you use the property so now that's this
part fine so we've covered the facts
we've covered some of the history to see
what's gonna happen to Derrick based on
what happened to Stacy okay
we've covered a power of what Darnell
affray sure does as a citizen
journalists right and how much of an
impact that smartphone has made to bad
cops and criminals we've talked about
good cops good protesters bad cops bad
protesters we've talked about logic and
reason now let's go a little bit more
over here who's behind this now what's
causing this who to blame that's really
the issue who is to blame
is it Trump it's Trump's fault no it's
not Trump's fault Obama is who divided
America no no it's not Obama's fault
it's the Democrats no it's the
Republicans no you know it's Soros as
George Soros his fault no it's the Koch
brothers it's Charlie Charles since he's
the one that's it's Charles's fault he
buys his president he wakes up in the
morning says for your birthday I'm gonna
buy you this present it's his fault it's
the educational system it's the whites
fault it's the black man's fault it's
the black person no it's the white man's
fault whose fault is it
maybe it's the media's fault why is it
the media's fault huh
what about my media's fault Pat I don't
know some of my media well who benefits
the most from America being divided
actually think about that question if
you're gonna have a debate tonight with
your family if you're gonna ask a
question to kind of start a conversation
with your kids maybe ask the question
who benefits the most from America being
divided
actually think about that who does who
benefits the most from America being
divided is it a political party do
Democrats benefit if we're divided or do
Republicans benefit if we're divided
who's the enemy is the China the China
benefit the more they look at America
and say oh my gosh awesome look at all
these protesting
it's beautiful you think China's excited
we're having protests cigarette I
actually think about it
you think China's excited you think
Russia's maybe excited do you think the
Middle East is excited laughing at
America saying look what you're doing
and you're judging us you think they're
excited
you think the Middle East is excited or
do you think the media is excited why is
the media excited why is it media
excited why is the media actually
excited well the media's excited because
if if Darnell afraser502 own life and
she's got a hundred thousand people that
are watching her life guess who's
winning Facebook is winning Facebook did
you see did you see watch this no way
Facebook wins traffic hmm
Facebook's our formal media right did
you see on the news did you see the news
did you see the news watch this no CNN's
in a box on who wins media ones the more
we divide it we are the less divided we
are the less we watch TV now watch this
person asked me question says you know
what you know this one CEO that I'm
mentoring he says I mean I mean the I'm
in the pastry business and I make these
cookies is what he makes whatever he
calls them I make these pastries I said
and he's afraid is that a good market to
be a part of I said when do people buy
pastries good times or bad times I don't
know that's okay let me ask the question
a different way when do people drink
alcohol more good times or bad times
when do you drink more alcohol when your
marriage is doing great or you just got
a divorce your wife leaves you your
husband leaves you you go to the bar
you're drinking when you drink alcohol
when do you drinks as smoke cigarettes
when stress is high when stress is high
there's a lot of great industries that
do well including new media do you
really think media wants to see United
United States of America do you really
think that I don't know do you really
think they're excited about us getting
along do you really think it profits
them I don't know let's continue why
does it keep happening why does it keep
happening I have a conversation I'm the
guy that likes to ask everybody so
what's on email what do you think about
what's going on why does this keep
happening
can we really stop this from happening
really can
racism discrimination really be
eliminated do you really think racism
and discrimination can be eliminated do
you really think that do you really
think racism and discrimination can be
eliminated by the way when we think
about racism
all we think about is what racism of
whites - blacks right racism of whites -
blacks I can tell you for me when I was
a kid going to high school when I went
to high school all the kids that had
their nice cars parked outside the BMW
convertibles were white a lot of them
and I was a middle-eastern from a
divorced family mom and dad broke and
I'm driving in 1979 Honda hatchback
yellow and it only goes drive it doesn't
go reverse five hundred dollars is all
my dad could afford to buy a car for me
in nineteen seventy nine hundred court
and I'm looking all these BMW people I'm
competing with all these guys you don't
think secretly you're sitting there
saying you know what you privileged
little bamm-bamm Papa of course I was in
a way not excited about it so who is
really racist can blacks be racist
against whites or is it just White's
against Blacks are there black people
that don't like white people are there
white people that don't like black
people are there Latinos are there
racism is not going away it's just a
flat-out thing I think the one the
biggest challenge for people to think
that racism is 100% gonna go away yes it
is less today than it was 20 years ago
than it was 50 years ago than it was a
hundred years gonna was if a person says
how could you say that look what's
happening to America right now how could
you say that yeah how could you give the
argument of the fact that we don't you
know racism it's not more today than it
is before because it's not we share
everything we go same rust we go
everywhere together right there's no
such thing as we don't go to a certain
place earlier it is better today than it
was before
will it 100% be eliminated I don't know
about that why we're always
discriminating and judging people we
discriminate people based on their
colors all the time we discriminate
people against their height look how
tall he is we discriminate against
weight we discriminate against
nationality we discriminate against
small feed you ever seen men that have
small feet what do you tell them I'll
look at that guy the guy with size six
feet shoes what's the first thing you
said when you see a man with small feet
actually think about that's a form of
judging discriminating right what are we
doing when we see people with small
hands oh look it Trump's got small hands
remember no the whole thing was about
small hands what do you do when you
shake someone's hands it's very small
and it's like sweaty you know those
hands when you shine like oh my gosh you
are good did you see how small that
guy's hands or did you you you that's a
form of discriminating judging somebody
right
bald big nose big ears clothes watch
tattoos or he's got tattoos he must be a
tough guy or that guy doesn't have
tattoos he must be a just a stuck-up guy
and square guy look at him he doesn't
have any tattoos would you get judged
whether you have him you get judged
where you don't have him right car what
you drive no matter what is this really
gonna go away you really think that's
100% gonna go away you really think that
I don't thinks gonna go you're at Venice
Beach you're about to pick your team
okay you got five guys lined up you got
first pick one of the guys is a seven
one white guy everybody else is black
they're all five eight five nine five
eleven you playing basketball who do you
pick up this seven one white guy you're
discriminating it is a form of
discrimination you're picking out why
don't you pick the other guy right yeah
yeah you got you got an audience you're
looking at five people you want to pick
to be your financial advisor out of the
four three of them are wearing ripped
shorts and ripped shirt
one of them's wearing a nice nice Zegna
suit ferragamo shoes and buckle and a
nice Rolex watch which one you're hiring
to be a financial adviser you understand
what I'm saying here that's a form of
discrimination we all jump to conclusion
and judge people all the time you do it
when you go to a nightclub you do when
you go into the store you do everything
we do we do this is this really gonna go
away I don't know about that now let's
keep continuing to your 2020 census race
questions this is for me okay this is
for me who do I identify with I'd go and
say let me you what's my race you know
today what you see on the list if you
want to pull it up you can go 2020
census rates question it says white I'm
not white it says black or
african-american I'm not black or
african-american it says American
indian/alaska native I'm not I'm not
either are you Asian I'm not Asian are
you Native American or Native Hawaiian
or Pacific either
I'm not what am i other there is no
Syrian Armenian Iranian or Middle
Eastern why not
I'm offended when I came to the States
you know it's crazy when I came to the
States is I was called this in Germany
and in u.s. but more here than in
Germany I was called turban hair
I was called camel jockey you know how
many people thought I went to school on
a camel like literally I said do you
hate camel jockey do you go on at school
on the camel I go to school on the
camera like I've never seen a camel in
my life now donkeys different story we
happen to me arena we don't have camels
I've never seen a camel so I've been you
going to school on a camel job I've been
called a terrorist
many times by the way in the army I've
been called them many times
Taliban you name it anything that like
that I've been called so now watch watch
what happens with me I become an advisor
day before 9/11 Morgan Stanley Dean
would I get my license eventually I'm
going to another company TransAmerican
I'm training this one guy who is a
Mormon I'll never forget this nicest guy
even his wife I met him when I'm in the
elevator going down to Universal Studios
movie with my girlfriend at the time I
see these two guys making out hardcore
I'm like dude this isn't it out of
control like kissing and touching and
all this other something I'm looking at
my girl McLobster pretty good for these
guys man like maybe we should like team
up right now as well then kind of
getting on the elevator because these
guys are going at it right so I'm like
hey why are you guys so crazy oh we just
got married three hours ago okay then yo
Scott it's who got married and your
honeymoon is that yeah this was just
kind of it's just a basic rudiment okay
cool so I talk to him I am then
eventually in the recruit him he becomes
an adviser he was a future commodity
broker so he starts working my guys name
is James and I trained him when I
trained him we want to client never
forget this
we go to this client Thousand Oaks nice
family money beautiful home and I go and
I say yes I'm a financial adviser I'd
like to be able to help you out with
your finances this is my specialty is
and they said were you from I said Iran
and they said are you a Mormon yourself
I said no we said you know what we would
like to work with somebody that's Mormon
if you don't mind if you have any
advisors that are Mormons we'd like to
talk my said but I'm probably the best
guy we have at our office right on my
company says no we'd like to talk to
Mormon look are you freaking kidding me
I can't do it I was Sophia I can't show
it to him because it's a guy I'm
training he's trying to power don't
worry about your pad I'm so sorry family
you know how they are they just kind of
said now it's all good man don't worry
about it but I was upset you have no
idea how pissed off I was when that took
place because I don't want to be judged
with what I am when I start an insurance
company it's one of the most annoying
stories ever for me
I saw the insurance company and this big
company you know the name it's a massive
company fortune 100 company very big
company we're at an event at napa valley
and my son is six months old and I took
my data my wife and they're going to
different events and the main guy the
main guy number three guy in the company
they're going baking and cooking with a
group my wife and my dad take my spot
I'm supposed to go I say my dad to go my
wife so they go the guy starts talking
to my wife because he was a new guy that
came on board he talks to my wife and he
says well let me ask you you know we're
a little bit concerned because what do
you think about Armenians yourself
Jennifer and she's he's talking like
what do you mean we know we've had a lot
of insurance companies and we dealt with
a lot of Armenians and a lot of
insurance fraud happens amongst
Armenians so we're a little bit
uncomfortable working with your husband
because he's Armenian you know so how do
you feel about that and he's trying to
pry stuff out of my wife I'm like wow
you kid so they come back and I just my
first time I'm getting this much time of
my six-month-old son so they come back
they come back my dad says please don't
say anything to Patrick please don't say
anything to Patrick guess what my mom my
wife says I have to tell him something
my wife comes to whisper to me what was
said she says it to me I fall about I
said he said what he says I have to tell
Patrick or else Patrick's gonna get
upset when she tells me I contact my
attorneys I contact my advisers that
contact I said what is this so while you
can't really do anything because you
can't prove all this other stuff so okay
great they were getting ready to come to
my office to drop my contract so I
called a meeting even sooner I asked him
to fly out and come to me they came one
week sooner at my office I'm there
my wife my chief compliance officer
Director of Finance my team he's sitting
right there across the table from me
okay and he says well let's go on and
get he's thinking he's gonna drop the
concept before we get started let me
start the meeting first before you do is
that fair
yes go ahead okay I said look there's
this little rumor going around that
you're uncomfortable working with us
because the CEO of the company happens
to be Armenian and you've had some
challenges working with Armenian brokers
in the insurance space and I just want
you to know for somebody that lives in
America where the system is run on a
capitalistic society this is what I'll
like to see happen with us I like to
just you to judge me based on the
results we get you not based on me being
Armenian and I like to make this a
business issue not a race or nationality
issue are you comfortable with that I'll
never forget this meaning he goes like
this you've made your point
great we're gonna give you one year and
I said no problem do you have anything
to talk about no meeting ended five
minutes they walked out
we've been still doing business with
these guys still today you know what
happened with that guy we became very
good friends upon his retirement in
Miami Florida we rented a yacht to
retire the five people that give
speeches on his retirement and the last
one that spoke was his best friend I was
a second to the last speaker that gave a
speech on his retirement because I
wanted respect and the way I got it is
to become number one in this space
Middle Eastern no four-year degree
nothing parents divorce zero money dad
99-cent store army background there's
nothing about me that says this guy's
gonna be a great CEO insurance agent the
point I'm trying to make use all of this
I used it as fire because this is only
to me to a couple different things here
when I was a kid I asked my mom I said
mom are we Democrats or Republicans you
know my mom said my mom said Democrats
are for the poor Republicans are for the
rich you know what I told my mom I said
man I'd love to be a Republican one day
I don't know what the hell Republican is
all I try to say I'm looking forward to
being rich one day cuz I hate it being
poor I hated it and why do I want to be
in a political party where it's only for
the poor I want to do something big
myself that's how I viewed it I didn't
know what Democrats were about I don't
know pro-life pro-choice I don't know
any of that stuff I just knew one
party's for the poor one party's for the
rich so in my mind went to why why would
I want to be for a party that looks at
me as being poor I don't want you to
look at me I've never liked when
somebody looks at me as being poor being
a victim
so now I want you look at me as being
poor I'm rich I'm in America I'm rich
it's better than being on Iran I'm such
a rich person just to be in America just
give me an opportunity let me prove my
said that was a mindset right
so if you look at voting today and again
this videos this a mainly
african-american topic here and by the
way my company 18% is african-american
just so you know this 18% is
african-american we're a company that's
very much a big african-american
community I got great relationship with
all of them phenomenal relationship with
all of them and by the way they're not
Republicans they're Republicans
Democrats independents and those who
could care less about politics they're
business people who's who they are let's
talk about voting in 1960 sixty-four
percent of African Americans voted
Democrat let me say that one more time
in 1960 64 percent of African Americans
voted for Democrat in 1964 that's 64
percent one to 92 percent again 1960
sixty-four percent voted Democrat 1964
92 percent voted Democrat in four years
we went from 64 percent Democrat 36
Republican to 92 percent Democrat why
because of Goldwater Coldwater went out
there and the whole 3/5 compromise he
didn't want to vote because he says he
felt they wanted to get more and I came
on and said wait a minute that
Republican because for the longest time
African Americans were you know the
Republican side Jackie Robinson was
campaigning for the Republican side you
can't go back and look at all that stuff
on what happened because Abraham Lincoln
was the first Republican he was a guy
that won civil rights and the guy gets
assassinated because all these slave
owners like wait a minute
what are you doing to our business are
you out of your mind no I'm not with it
this is what we're doing so most African
Americans that I know they're very
conservative they're raised a lot of
them very very conservative folks right
but that changed voting wise from 1964
until 2020 Democrats have
african-americans have given the
Democratic votes to them all of it from
1964 2020 blacks have voted Democrats 88
to 92 percent of time it's been all
Democrats right so the question you
gotta ask yourself is how does that work
for you
what's happened what has happened for
you what kind of results because you've
given Democrats the ability to make the
right changes for you they've had 56
years to be able to come out with new
programs new legislation
they've been able to do make changes
what's happened for you so Charlemagne
God has Joe Biden on he says listen I
just want to be able to know that the
Democrats don't abuse the you know the
black vote right that's what Charlotte
mean gone joe biden said if you vote for
trump you in black you know that's kind
of like what barry goldwater did do you
know 3/5 compromise they lose all the
black vote the democrats don't think
they'll lose the black vote so what am i
saying my same board republican it's not
what i'm saying this is my solution
because everything to me is with
solution all these things we're talking
about number one change the way you vote
if you're not going to vote republican
vote independent or third party you they
have to get a taste it's not just you're
automatically going to get my vote
because this is now working in number to
help communities become financially free
help communities become financially free
through what doe through capitalism and
entrepreneurship can you imagine if more
like for me i'm gonna make more money so
nobody can tell me what to do your
middle-eastern dough you're none of
these on the census your Arminianism you
look like some of these guys when 9/11
look like that guy could be your uncle i
know but when you get results nobody can
tell you anything and that's the
Entrepreneurship side select the
philosophy get so good at what you do
that whites blacks Latinos everybody
wants to do business with you because
they don't look at this get so good at
what you do because the reality of it is
what is really the solution to this all
of these things that's happening it's
just bringing awareness but awareness to
what solution who's talking solution I'm
only interested in solutions I fully
understand everybody wants to get on the
bandwagon why not give some solutions
how do you change yes you can raise
money and give money and go from sure
all of those things are good but they're
not permanent fixes they're band-aids
what are your permanent solutions I'm
making some suggestions I'm making some
suggestion that this is what I would be
doing if I was F if I was somebody that
was a president and if I have somebody
that's making decisions these are the
things I'm talking about when is the
last time you see somebody from the top
start telling people to go read books on
business when why not why not tell
somebody go read these 10 business books
go
learn how to be an entrepreneur go learn
how to be a capitalist why because if
you do they don't own you don't own the
boat you control how you vote because
they need you not the other way around
so again while you're talking about this
reason why I get a little bit upset is
because I don't like being bullied I
don't like being manipulated I don't
like being pushed around I don't like
being owned I don't like being owned
Democrats owned the vote I don't like
being owned I'm Armenian I'm a Syrian
I'm Iranian sixty-five percent of us
also vote Democrat I don't like being
owned I'm a registered independent right
in the middle I don't like being owned I
don't like people to hell we know for a
fact he's gonna vote for us we know for
a fact he's got a clean no no you don't
know for a fact you gotta earn it
let's go you got earned it and I think
this is time if you want to be free
let's make some real long-term solutions
so again I don't have all the answers
this is my suggestion I want to hear
from you on what your suggestions are on
commenting below and I got a video I
want you to watch it's called how to
reach your full potential if you never
watch this video before click over here
to watch the video how to reach your
full potential and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
all bye
you
[Music]